toby is a farmer he plants 12 rows of
carrots in a field each row has six
carrots how many carrots did toby plant
so let's try to visualize this thing so
they tell us each row has six carrots
let's try to visualize a row so that's
one carrot that's two carrots that's
three carrots that's four carrots that's
five carrots and that's six carrots and
i can even do just so it looks nice a
little leafy part of the carrots so this
we can visualize these as carrots so
that's one row of carrots they tell us
each row has six carrots
now there are 12 of these he plants 12
rows of carrots let me see if i can copy
and paste this
so
copy and paste so that's two rows
make sure i have enough space two rows
that's three rows
that's four rows
this is five rows
this is six rows and actually i can just
copy and paste the whole thing this is
six rows and you just need to double
that to get to 12 rows let me do that
so
copy and paste there you go so there's
12 rows right over here and let's number
this so they tell us they tell us each
row has six carats
one two three four five six they tell us
he plants a total of twelve rows
one two three
four five six seven
eight nine ten
eleven twelve how many carrots did toby
plant well you could do this exercise
and then try to count all of these
carrots but that seems a little bit
crazy these are already a lot of carrots
and especially if these were even larger
numbers would take you forever to count
it luckily for us we have multiplication
as a tool at our
we have multiplication as a tool that we
can use so if you have 12 rows and each
of those rows have 6 this is really 12
times 6.
you're going to have 12 rows and each of
those you have 6 carats so you could say
you have 6 carats 12 times so it's going
to be 12 times 6. if you remember your
multiplication tables up to 12 you'll
remember that 12 times 6 is 72. so he
has 72
72 carats even if you only remember well
i'll just leave it there if you remember
your multiplication tables which you
should because that is one of the things
in life that is will will have long
lasting benefits
72 carats